[Music]
[Applause]
on the across the pavement
[Music]
[Applause]
nice
[Music]
[Applause]
inducing people of no faith and from all
parts of the world and that's the way
we're always going to keep it we all
wore the rights of the Palestinian
Sydney we have authorized of all
oppressed people all around tomorrow
welcoming drugs that are spread in the
budget
[Applause]
[Music]
that Oh like this cos we are black they
don't like this because we of woolsley
little I can still be a Christian they
don't like sisters we're Jewish they
don't like us because we're people in
those things you just don't like anybody
not like this what we see today is
through against really flax belonging to
the far right the far right and the
Zionists are all in one step best friend
is Donald Trump
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
the river to the Palestine will be free
will be sane in a fiber cocaine from the
river to the sea
to the sea
sister's friend ghali
children family members black white
Christian Muslim Jew in to see it all
outside over here they're all an answer
for the people fish suppose
[Applause]
[Music]
one turtle beer I'm missing 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15
about 20 of them stop by the firehouse
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
sorry
[Applause]
oh so incredible we love gather Polly
Polly Polly a new college life they've
got a Jeremy we've got her to me
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
[Applause]
like again for coming we love you so
much I knew you better than New Zealand
to get mobile you get both new ways to
take all the swear he had enemies of
spitting to stop throwing them either
we've seen on this possession and
eternal Jerry please make some noise for
the robbers
another brothers from Abraham can I tell
you you are joined here by many fellow
semak's many fellow semak's the sons of
Ishmael are with you ok so some of
Ishmael are with the sons of arctic we
are together we're all symmetric on the
sides the audience's Emmerich's are on
top side waving
[Applause]
[Music]
what are those posted societies
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
again
[Music]
[Applause]
the guy
[Music]
[Applause]
by
oh no oh yes cross the road then I think
like you know I'm messy whatever stairs
[Applause]
[Music]
which resistance we gather here today
outputs 2019 is now the procession
itself is an upload and rejection of
Google Maps and Romania because
literally in 16 minutes the wall
[Music]
so we women goodbye at resume about
survival the tension on the other side -
[Music]
pretty impressive
impressive
I can't deal facades for anybody no
kidding well
[Music]
[Applause]
against them with our Jewish brethren
without visiting breath with a breath
away
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
give them a round of applause that makes
acknowledge
blackberries of Palestine makes this
noise below
[Applause]
yeah
somebody like to do the five minutes
with no food
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
this is called the beach
but the proof of their assertion the
stupid
without mana wins
[Applause]
[Music]
because you gotta shoot detective in the
[ __ ] brain
[Applause]
[Music]
let's head
[Applause]
[Music]
one cherry is stuck in a sorry there's
no encoder self why we wouldn't event
are you so depressed
[Music]
[Applause]
relax yourself everyone relax
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
if we try
No
[Music]
it's
the Sun is beating the drums born years
old 3 3 3 3 3
[Applause]
[Music]
the Westbridge
[Applause]
they're going straight up we're just
gonna turn there there's actually
nothing happening we have to get we were
just all get here quickly
[Applause]
[Music]
my car's not moving the smokin
[Applause]
the way
[Music]
side mission tell Alicia
sound as you're gonna reserve
[Applause]
the crab is killer
[Music]
[Applause]
my cook segment
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm coming
Gaza Hamas Free Gaza from us joy the new
gazing Gaza gazing gazing
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a just until you open it which
counter got a big ass
keep the pace up try to break out
[Applause]
[Music]
I know
during the wood
that's gonna be making install shows
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm in life
[Music]
[Applause]
okay moving them please guys
Theresa burners are straight
[Music]
what I'm going to do is I'm in Korean
to keep it straight
[Applause]
[Music]
No
[Applause]
Terry suppose
the scouts
[Applause]
[Music]
save us another
[Applause]
[Music]
did any of you boys to me did anyone get
it on film
[Applause]
that's what
[Music]
[Applause]
so either down the road across Nicholas
nice nice yeah it's moving across I
decided the road apart beside other side
of the road
[Applause]
hey guys
Piper keep moving with us economy
and don't shrink because we're walking
block instead of speaker this help
I still move with the pace okay going
across
excuse me
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Applause]
[Music]
one across across the circuit
what is that there's that one possum
circles nine
the basic American
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm talking about full toys outside
upstairs
[Applause]
[Music]
for each of the keys they're going to do
it aside you guys are right
[Applause]
Thanks although you couldn't ask me to
move you wanted and you've come back you
see me I'll just go with you okay moving
please and you sir
[Applause]
[Music]
right
so with the various plates that might
please
under guard
nice
[Applause]
[Music]
was Eric we shake
[Applause]
do
- nice ring sizes like free free
Palestine free free Palestine free free
fighting inside ring ring - not free
by this time free by this
[Applause]
[Music]
we all know
[Applause]
[Music]
invite as you know we Scott all my
thoughts with rendition from the Holy
Quran the holy comfortable slips so can
I borrow some Ajay to recite I will
request that you remain silent let the
rubber behind this
the fascists I have behind this design
so let's please it's a quietness and
reflect what's listening to well reflect
on all the struggles all of the world of
all the oppressed people especially the
Palestine is further ado please welcome
with a nice town salawah
I
[Music]
min ash-shaytaan-i'r rajeem right
you
[Music]
my name
maybe nothing morally
your jaw hit the moon apiece I feeling
[Music]
Luna
yah-hoo
[Music]
his phone line
thank you brother London's up close 2019
make some girls
[Applause]
we went past the party living with their
way and we don't care what color what
nationality what religion as I guess
this design is the designers we don't
agree with their ideology and we also
know we've got some Muslims in
Parliament who are also famous do we
know so cumbersome of someone into
joining of this book in other words we
are yo yo are you ready are you ready
the Parliament has some Muslims the
British Parliament has some Muslims
those Muslim societies British
Parliament also Muslims
and some of those desires with an outfit
carrot when every day helping up and
ever knowing everyone I'm gonna fake
British Parliament House so give me some
love chair
[Applause]
it's been a short session all right okay
[Music]
naked
and instead is college you teaching at
the school of oriental studies his books
include a best-selling introduction to
the Holocaust the context village with
Konami the conflict
and 2012 the professor completely the
grill burning on the August
let me tell you it's not easy for people
like Professor Han to speak up against
diseases it's very difficult they can
abuse they got told also from people in
Israel all set when they stand here
Charlotte's shoulder with all of us
standing 20 women backs of the
Palestinians to live freely in that
country please make some noise for
doctor profession hey Rishi
we by the rabbi's Alden Lamar this is
symbolic I bring you greetings from the
Jewish Network to Palestine we are a
sister organization of the Jewish boys
at least in the US and this are with you
today they traveled Palestine and it's
suffering on this day of Ramadan just in
the context of a manufactured crisis
because anti-semitism on the Left I wish
to remind us that until the
establishment of Israel choose it lived
in peace and safety in the Arab and
Islamic world never suffering excessive
aggression and anti-semitism you don't
bokya of all kinds who remains the
European Commission phenomenon in rate
control a role played by Jews in
Rockwell will be hostile world all level
of society in Oh
Jewish one of collaboration cooperation
and coexistence this is what example
Pennsylvania is most rocks they live
together of discrete religious sons and
daughters of a ground Jews were
integrated into society and play a
crucial role in Spain and work together
on real texts without those translations
for the Arabic back into Latin Europe
will not have their most important
Ottoman Empire in the world is not least
in Palestine press three religions
enjoyed single point
not seen before or a violinist brutally
shuttin such rich dishes by Florida
installing racial hatred colonial
disdain towards the Palestinians
indigenous population together with
those who are at risk and subjugated
harder
occupation and konami machine we can
treatment our decisions especially in
the placated gather and go for all of us
britain to use boycott divestment and
sanctions to bring about the end of
scientism and it's cruel practices to
bring about just lasting peace and
coexistence for all who live in
palestine as well as the palestinian
refugees living abroad and the secular
democratic state has to falsify the PLO
the sole presentative palestinians
palestine shall be free gaza shall be
free all people in palestine shall be
free free free Palestine free free pasta
in a hundred and our millions we are all
Palestinians free Palestine
[Applause]
[Music]
Hey sign this sign alone graphic
[Applause]
let's level without set up the campaign
against criminalized communities in
early 2001 previously using both with
the campaigns against urbanization he
has opposed Israeli occupation through
various UK campaigns Churchill's Jews
football coaching is really good Jewish
Network for Palestine I'm British
Committee for the universal Palestine
please put your hands together make some
dough Oh
[Applause]
we are here today to demand that Israel
demand abandon is colonization of
Palestine and that Western governments
young companies
he stopped supporting the colonization
project protests often demands and the
occupation referring to the 1967 seizure
of the West Bank and Gaza declared
illegal by UN resolutions but that
seizure only extended the original
colonization function which established
the State of Israel in 1948 and which
recognizes no permanent boundaries over
the last couple decades further
colonization has turned the two-state
solution into a fantasy but it remains a
necessary
for Western governments to collude with
further colonization through its liberal
support arms sales technology
development security cooperation in
Israel and so-called anti-terrorist
hours these powers have been used to
label liberation movements as terrorists
and to sanitize state terrorism as
counterterrorism this is a broader
pattern worldwide played by Western
governments especially the UK in
supporting terrorist States supporting
Saudi Arabia's terrorism against Yemen
supporting stirpes terrorism against its
Kurdish population supporting India's
terrorism against Kashmir and its Muslim
population and so on the European Union
likes to portray itself as humanitarian
that it funds the Israeli military
industrial project through its research
and development programs as well as by
subsidizing the occupation simply
rebuilds facilities that are destroyed
by Israel Israel's most important winner
the US government has intensified its
support for Israeli come colonization
under the Trump regime
in particular it is unilaterally
recognized Israel's illegal annexation
of East Jerusalem it's moved this
embassy to Jerusalem to close the US
consulate there and close the PLO office
in Washington it also recognized
Israel's annexation of the Syrian Golan
hates us president has also announced
the so-called deal in the century
supposedly to resolve the conflict the
threat of even more punishments the
Palestinian representatives declined the
offer how do we understand these changes
according to some critics the Trump
regime has ruptured the international
consensus and that the US government is
no longer an honest broker but was it
ever as we know it really means that the
match has dropped the mask has dropped
from the imperialist agenda that always
characterized u.s. administration's this
more blatant reality
for collaboration in Arab regimes and
for Palestinian representatives who
prefer the deceptive mask of imperialism
now the viene Palestine National
Authority which has helped Israel to
release the Palestinians
since 1993 now it faces unstable and
uncertain rewards for its collaboration
when these stains on summers are very
great decision
we must mobilize our supporters to
counter the threats especially through
the campaign boycott divestment
sanctions BDS everybody knows dumped by
Israeli days and that symbolically in
Oregon that's just the individual
boycott the most important EBS actions
are targeting institutions targeting
since my pension funds investments by
British banks here I want to encourage
everyone to join in the campaign against
HSBC which has been arming Israel
through its investments in several large
companies and its investments in Cadogan
booth bulldozers have been used
systematically to destroy Palestinian
homes HSBC conveniently for us has
branches all over the country to be easy
to get together with your friends and
start making it
[Applause]
[Music]
all the way from : anyone else in
Slovenia
we're friends
an attentive friend
[Applause]
don't say no way so may not be as well
known to you the previous speech is
taken in the middle and missing
everywhere believe me I'll see the type
of filter by the fascists and the racist
to do so please give a round of applause
make some noise and a big welcome all
the way from Scotland make good as a
Scottish comedian called Frankie Boyle
and he tells a joke Sooners notable
canon cardboard Stefan from the usual
detective story because she see the
mountain at the beginning and then on
programas hunterson you try to only drop
the Montella when you see another
depending it's artists and your face and
he tells a joke to his granny who says
during a program cheated we should be
killing him knows it
it's open to the public there's a guy
just been suspended from the Labour
Party for saying the Australian you see
is behind the whole wave of aunties of
gods
phony faith malicious and disseminate
some allegation he's been suspended for
saying something and maybe think you do
leaking oil Joe and so this really is a
Vasa they did openly they have workshops
around the country where all the work of
Zions get together Christians and
Muslims and Jews they all get the devil
desires because there are some of each
and they taught how to a sphere those of
us who stand up the Palestinian people
you're trying today is the stand up for
the noble people of Palestine but I have
to tell you there are reasons to cut
your wrists there are many reasons to
despair a sex abuser is modern
entertained by the Queen in London
today's his money here paragraph Ivana
he should be present for so many reasons
the disparity but when you see the
Polish Lenin started out running day
after Friday week after week be mounted
by snipers and still they come by how
did we despair the cost of resistance
invention is very small it doesn't cost
money but they are feared people get
fired from the job very few get killed
it doesn't cost very much the spangled
the net one strike against the
palestinian people and you here today
are dying and you're inspiring other
people who want you and don't quite have
the courage to join today but my final
that courage the world friends the
horror in palestine gets worse and worse
with every year and now it's open marker
the United Nations Human Rights Council
a few weeks ago reporting I wrote
Ezreal is telling children knowing that
they are Chao
it's telling the portal is telling
disabled Palestinians knowing that they
are disabled this is like bloody
Tennessee another government has
condemned the urine console for making
that report the Foreign Minister of
Britain attract the UN Council
Amnesty International but the British
government attacked the council and said
it was unbalanced friends how to give me
balance between snipers for a year
muttering people in front of them and
the people have been martyred how can
you be balanced
that's a pathological condition it's
wrong not to support the Palestinians
it's unhealthy and I look at you today
and I draw inspiration from your hell
you study on your determination to be
counted the Muslims the Jews are those
of us who are more religious believers
respond together I'll finish my scene
the hoarder constantly gets worse
the British government complicity is
never-ending
I tell you special but the Machine
Bowser with Scottish Tony Blair the
Scottish we have a lot of ground to make
up and we're trying to a German Ally
but the complexity of the Finnish
government is profound and deep and
black and profitable but the resistance
of the Palestinians is detonating
support around the world to fight a
Gallup poll in America two months ago
said the great majority of young people
in America support Palestine and I'm not
drawn to our support for Israel was an
entity I discussed it with Israel and
the leaders of this community are
complaining about the young people
because he could support Nashville they
don't do mr. Northam friends we will win
nothing sure that he's never been a
movement for human progress
I can't slavery that didn't bring a
novel última street to support slavery
it was November before the vote for men
of the woman that they bring around
such as these have turned asleep to
oppose it
we are standing for human freedom to
stand against the forces of Mother Earth
with lensing and genocide
we will went and the Martin and not much
today and the future courses find
pleasurable and I mean Teresa may God
help us for Boris Johnson when do you
think an end to fight next speaker is
actually a point we're going to appoint
a very very special power before line
boys
Pyrus Odin Barba soldiers mention every
one of us is the young boy mr. boy
we went out to draw stones against the
tank we've seen his picture around I
think I chose EOS of t-shirts made by
the minute
his name should be etched his name shall
be taught to every child to all our
children when children write about who
the heroes are in school district oh I'm
right - my father saw their electric
violin cheering - come on recite the
poem will be the beautiful and it'll
damage of arabic the language of hora so
that leads with a nice this especially
the members of our sordid
oh I feel so sad
so thoughtful grout to learn what
immortal building your age being blinded
lifeless normal extinguish walls and our
[Music]
without
and I love food so and why you matter
for you are till utilizes like Jesus the
Christ and immoral and defies before God
for God cannot do you charge for me were
all ages at you not a form of dignity
beyond the time like the children
surprising like the rocks and the trees
in our gardens you die stand and we'd
our stand we die
I apologize I was English
today I invite another organization that
spends a lot of time
standing on the aggressor to see a lot
of these real things protection
two more after this whether sparring
come here take some noise for
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
my Special Branch
[Music]
was just
[Applause]
[Music]
it was a huge
[Applause]
but she's always victims of exiting the
next person
my father was going on his way this
chakra is impermeable upon which he was
attacked by far-right extremist both of
you many of you will know about a
situation
so it's really really grateful that
process took the trouble to come to
address it
can we please welcome Mouse but some
cheers yes this area too many party
come on let's get those lungs going
tradition
[Applause]
- its London 2019
make some noise Oh silly
[Applause]
once again
[Music]
infrastructure the idea that instead of
trying to say okay wait
[Music]
Israel the British Foreign Secretary
chopped 22 support for his lovers metal
I think he's going to get enough workers
who taught still of the same
or
[Music]
[Applause]
flashes drone pizza fashion
let's get this next feat knowing that
planet and other people's eyes this
video length logo that went viral
he told the Zionists to that face what
we think about them no fear in his eyes
nothing is voice trampled he stood firm
and in fact Oh every single word he said
[Applause]
[Music]
I just have a point out as you know
President Trump has proposed a deal
century to resolve the conflicts in
Palestine brokered by the son-in-law
Jared Kushner I think that's a very good
move we have to welcome a deal is a deal
that we need to resolve
however we accepted even and Palestinian
but the point is that you cannot set the
channel because you are in the teens and
the resistance is an advance and they
were losing between cannot sell between
the time of a deal which is going to be
the deal of sense I tell you you are to
receive because you a victor
in 33 days war in Lebanon by the hands
of Hezbollah fighters Valley repeats
because we were defeated by resistance
in the recent attack on Gaza we are will
repeat because I am no truth to the
useless could not stop the measurements
coming from Gaza well it appears because
the resistance is in its strongest
Taliban and you are in your weakness and
when I say you are you America and
Israel together and all their supporters
you are in retreat because you are
taking Iran for negotiation you haven't
received because the consensus people of
the world are no you don't believe your
fallacies anymore you are in retreat
because you have lost the ethical
grounds for your existence
and therefore it is the resistance who
sets the terms of the deal of the
century and I tell you this deal is
going to happen and it's going to happen
soon in the first half of the century
not to the end of the session now I
mentioned if you agree with these terms
please support it with shouting free
free Palestine one the first term of the
deal
America must be the Middle East
she does not belong there and during his
history in the region has only caused
bloodshed carnage and strike
to the west master stock is staggering
activities in the region I tell you this
is not your region
this is our region we can solve our
problem ourselves and you have if you
are interested you have to seek
somewhere else in out my other news
because now the resistance is not
letting you to take the benefit from the
people of the region which of course
their money is is taken away by those
governments which are so-called
allowance so I I mentioned the second
term if we are limited say free
Palestine the West must stop is
destabilizing activities in the region
three designers must leave Palestine
that thought that the teens Christians
and Muslims can live peacefully in that
blessed land again like before the faith
political entity food Israel must be
dismantled students must have the rice
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the deal of the century and I
tell you this feeling is going to happen
it's going to happen in the first out
half of the 21st century and in China
all of us will see that day and the
disco is quite clear for what you are
hoping inshallah lovely Palestine
[Applause]
[Music]
do you see
to this day
you will say here will stay there for
shake my bumper make some noise
our next speaker is the editor-in-chief
from an online digital newspaper called
five pillars the beauty of five pillars
and try to unite all Muslims the things
and that you might not like things that
you like for us to do it the challenges
and it talks about all the issues a lot
of people don't want to so blades will
nice picture come we welcome
Roshan Mohamed Salah to come and give
his talk by signs changed narrative on a
star go on the offensive against Israel
and the sports
it's time that we made toxic to Israel
just as they try to make it toxic the
most to support Palestine Israel as a
terrorist state created by ethnic
cleansing created by selectively planned
and sustained to the war occupation and
oppression that's what these guys are
supporting know how proud of themselves
they must be and one day history of the
Denver just met in a Kazakh as them the
supporters the racist apartheid South
Africa note the two-state solution which
was killed by Israeli settlements dead
long time ago and with now only soil
cement is ready Germany over stolen
personal and the vast majority of
students religious and secular believe
it's dead so why this program strike
Germany Rubin insist on supporting the
two-state solution but he knows very
well that it means the destruction of
Palestine itself instead we have to talk
about the liberation of palestine and we
have to talk about a one state solution
where everyone shares the land
Israel has no moral right to make sense
our freedom again it has no moral right
to exist just like South Africa had no
right to exist saying Israel has no
right to exist this not me but we
declare the Jews into the sea just
sitting here with opposing apartheid
South Africa or white people it just
means that Israel has no right to exist
to exist at the expense of another
people no to the Israel of the
definition of anti-semitism otherwise
known as the ihr a definition of
anti-semitism it says that you are
anti-semitic it's the question Israel's
right to exist before Israel racist it's
just a means of silencing fasting and
wisdoms and harsh criticism of Israel no
to normalization with the Zionist entity
in any way whatsoever
my understanding of media's is the
all-encompassing boycott of Israel were
about the political cultural etc boycott
Israeli
but soft normalization is happening
right here in Britain it's simple
biggest mosques and Muslim institutions
playing footsie with Zionists under the
guise seemingly harmless interfaith
activities an interface is deliberately
being promoted by scientists as a means
of trying to establish Israel as a
better home clearly - Nicholas's
vomit and - bye mister by booster groups
goodbye otherwise proposal interfaith
with Zionists is a bit like breaking
bread with a burglar who just stole your
house the bird Allah says to you he
can't hide your house back but let's be
friends no let's not be friends so if
Muslims will do in to pay with Jews
let's do it Venetian ricotta let's move
some of the
demonstration we share our struggle
against a scientist entity it's their
voice he needs amplifying not silence
yes to existence let's not be shy about
that Palestinians as an occupied people
have the right to resist by any means
necessary and the occupied by power
Israel has an obligation to Patrol and
the law says that resistance can be
military they can be political cultural
academic etc etc and those who are too
open with the resistive struggle need
our support and if you can't support
them be quiet about it but don't
demonize them have the goal to save your
column for Palestine but I fear our
community leaders are selling the house
to be close down the river as we speak
to gain entrance in this house
controlled to get around the top table
in Downing Street to get those night
works to appear in the mainstream media
and if we don't stop them from going
down this shameless route then it will
become normal for Muslims
scientists the spelling out our
Palestinian brothers and sisters where's
the shame in our community leaders
where's their lever Palestine it's up to
us to change their minds
I wanna Muslim leadership that truly
reflects a community not their own
vested interests I want to get one of
the Muslim community that's led by lions
not bite mice we need to hold our
leaders to account to keep them honest
they work for us they gave up their
legitimacy for us not the other way
around
to conclude let me end by saying that
Israel may be sitting first now but in
the future will
20 I don't think so it's basically
demographic time bomb with the rise of
Palestinian population with
ultra-orthodox groups Jews in Israel not
serving in the army and not contributing
much the economy will this remote wing
matter America still be supportive of
this question permanent outpost when the
energy age finishes the whole region
becomes West region will America have
the same cultural affinity with Israel
as it does now when it becomes the non
majority non-white nation and will the
advent of multipolar world with the rise
of Austin Powers will they finally give
the person the Palestinians
the vacuum now that is not the answer to
these questions but I do know the time
is against Israel and inshallah and
these last days of Ramadan let's make it
could be later tonight let's make two a
for the end of the apartheid motion
there was some very salient points about
the current pitiful state of some of the
Muslims and their organizations are most
on this land interpret foolish
we don't live in interfaith what we
believe in the right interface with a
face not political ideology and that is
why we have the rabbi's commute exact
idea I know everyone who have mentioned
from me from the professor professor
heiny
from last weekend in the neck for
raising their voices including math
including worship and including check my
math book nobody nobody gets as far as
these guys number introduce now they get
it rarely but I have seen him being
physically punched I've seen a big spot
on I have seen them being called capo
and also so vile disgusting things on
our demo has got to come please put your
hands together
I make a nice picture from the rabbi's
of Newton
[Applause]
[Music]
my friends
we coming here to show our solidarity
with the Palestinian people it's not the
only place maybe come in a school a to
show the Jewish solidarity with the
Palestinian people in a dominant cities
over the hall because this year among
simple answers emotionally because in
Canada in Montreal Toronto in New York
in California in Detroit in money money
cities over the world come to show
solidarity with a Castilian rebels
[Applause]
thousands of Jewish people whatever you
can the State of Israel come and look in
our neighborhood
I myself I needed time to deal not too
far for me
hundreds of institutions will find them
you will not see in one given a flag in
home it's 71 years 71 years the State of
Israel 74 years of killing 71 years of
oppression of a passion 71 years of
loving and the properties 74 means
giving inside a woman children it's very
painful for all people especially for us
the Jewish people but everything has
been done in our name in the name of the
Jews enable the devil in the name of God
what design is take out the concept
concept some lawyers to toe
[Music]
[Applause]
we Jews are going to go 10,000 eggs I
miss
we not die to go against them we believe
in you in our good times indeed in the
natural times we are not deduct like a
small-time Kings hands of his mother is
not worry for nothing
we also believe in a hundred percent but
the scientists lost the home state we
don't care about God we don't care about
his exile we going out by force leaving
to campus such a thing design and
acclaim gives a Jewish rabbi
that sign is kind of speaking
oh I can save it lady
teddy where you see the ad juice all the
horrible juice looks like me I can say
the vast majority of them sternly
designers in 95 you will not find even
one is a thread in the whole area
it not only is comfortable everywhere we
see a concentration of Jewish people
looks like me take my example country
take for example in the new stadium in
neither not mentioning the USA in New
York in Canada in many places Jewish
Jews like the signs of the call
themselves Jews mostly Jewish people
following God totally against the State
of Israel
- name they want to make a safe haven
for the Jewish people now in today's day
just a few eyes just look Jewish people
living in the whole world very very safe
they have no doubt that take my example
here mutate everywhere even in the
Muslim countries Jews means very
peacefully take for example young they
have allergies
people in their table they have their
synagogues they have their Institute's
they have just wood for the children
they had to own
they're not having them but the state
occasion today if the boss
danger please choose medium can choose
take this example
I need be ready take it again
I don't know how I can show - looks like
another soda but in Israel a smooth time
five years
[Music]
[Applause]
in the media if the policeman the same
there always block the Saints of old
hoxton however designs try to say to do
label of the Muslim Fitness entire
Jewish ever hunt is not anti-semitism
[Applause]
belief incentives in almost accountants
in these it's not love at all even today
companies
very good and as I told take for example
to meet Al Jean Morocco Yemen everywhere
to sleep at all only in the State of
Israel he a problem today yesterday I'm
always happy because they want to take
the women into the I mean give me the
musical track they go rather to prison
we go rather to be killed
because they say they stayed up must
come to an end we are not supporting a
two-state solution at all
they stay to be like a lien against
almighty in the top 40